let's talk about digital roses don't die
sir
love the title thank you i think it fits
the vibe of this project
you've dabbled with some funky [ __ ] in
the past
but i feel like with this album you
fully committed to just a different vibe
than when we get in the car and press
play on a qriket album yeah
where's your head where's your head at
when you're making this project and it
sounds amazing i think you executed it
amazingly thank you i mean for me i just
didn't want to
drop an album coming out of 2020 and
2021 that sounded like what people know
me for i wanted to
change and show the kind of growth not
only i've gotten mentally but
musically and grounded and comfortable
like i it's okay for me to make a funky
record of singing on my entire eye you
sound great singing man hey man i did my
best you sound good
not too much yeah but yeah who isn't
using tools let's be honest
[ __ ] using tunes on their
rapping versus but the thing was too bro
it's like you can't there's nobody to
feature for you in your life right yeah
so when writing this album it's like if
it's a love album the only two voices
that you hear constantly is me and um
this amazing singer named roland right
it's just back and forth for me and this
woman kind of relationship thing and so
records like generational way down it's
my story it's how i feel so despite how
many notes i might hit this bad i have
to sing this because it's how it's i
wrote it and it's
it's my personal experience and so
starting to think about music like that
kind of changed how i even approach our
album at this point right
and it's amazing that the girl talk
album is coming out because i get to be
young spirited you know maybe people
that miss that glass house country [ __ ]
but myself and that's cool but dallas
was in my 20s you know i'm in my 30s and
i'm supposed to grow and your fans are
growing man yeah i mean [ __ ] they got
kids most of them facts you know what
i'm saying or they they went through the
college experience and they're trying to
get their house you know
if you're thinking 2010 was doing i mean
that's 12 years yeah and i was but i
started my first project came out in
2004.
that's crazy you know what i'm saying
and so i've been i've i've done that and
i've been in 18 years yeah bro yeah the
first beat i ever made was in 1999. so
2001 i dropped my first mixtape in my
city it literally was uh 21 years ago
yeah wow yeah so it's like i've been
doing it to be able to be as vulnerable
as i was on this album to make a record
like more than roses and have that flute
the the dude killed it that was the
closest thing i've ever got to making
something willie hutch would make
something that i just got that way you
know and and to me that's that's that's
what i do this for bro i gotta challenge
myself it's very it it just gave me like
a really like timeless
feel yeah like this [ __ ] will live in
like 10 years it could have lived in
1978
and if you go with if you're in a
relationship it's something in this
album that's for you yeah you might be
you might not be with it now but you
don't worry
you'll go you'll go
you're gonna go through one of these
[ __ ] tracks you know now i love
the title too just like because we live
in a world in which everything is
digital and you know
what was your motivation to that digital
roses don't die well there was two
different perspectives the first one was
the fact that we document our
relationships in a sense and even if
you're not with that person that stuff
is still out there to see still on the
internet they could bring you down or it
can encourage you depending on how you
feel yeah i didn't think that but in the
grander scheme we've been digital way
longer than what we think my dad showed
me a picture of my uh sent me a picture
of my grandparents when they were super
young together and then i'm looking at
this and i'm like this is a digital rose
you know neither one of my grandparents
are here but this has been passed down
from generation to generation and i'm
gonna get to pass it down to my kids as
well so this is way bigger than it just
being the internet this is your own
personal experience and journey
being documented and people get to look
back at it and it goes from not only the
people in the picture but who took the
photo what was happening during that
time period you know we seen pictures of
people that deal with the spanish flu
and mask everybody you know we just saw
that yeah now we we we got photos like
that we got we got documented time we
gonna be like yeah we're living we're
living in history right now we don't
even realize it because we're in it i'm
like man what the [ __ ] were they wearing
man 15 years from now we're gonna look
back and be like y'all remember crazy
them two years were crazy and so and for
me it's just about expressing that and
wanting people to really take heed and
document and give those roses today to
each other now it's very important